a former Penn State fraternity brother
is the first to plead guilty to charges
related to the hazing death of 19 year
old Timothy Piazza Ryan Burke admitted
to nine charges yesterday including
hazing and unlawful acts involving
liquor 25 other former fraternity
members still face charges
Jericka Duncan is here with what led to
the guilty plea Arica good morning good
morning John Burke was accused of giving
a bottle of vodka to Piazza during a
hazing ritual at the Beta Theta Pi house
in February of 2017
Piazza died two days later from injuries
sustained after several dangerous Falls
and excessive drinking now Burke admits
he was partly to blame outside a County
Courthouse in Bellefonte Pennsylvania
Ryan Burke's attorney Philip Missouri
detailed Burke's decision to plead
guilty to charges related to the hazing
death of Timothy Piazza there are too
few words to describe a loss so great
this young man understands that mr.
Burke decided to step forward his
earliest opportunity
acknowledge and accept his
responsibility prosecutors say
surveillance footage shows fraternity
brothers gave Piazza at least 18 drinks
in about 82 minutes
Piazza suffered deadly injuries after
falling and hitting his head repeatedly
the footage revealed that during the
nearly 12 hours the brothers waited to
call 911 Piazza and slapped him while he
was passed out in March we spoke to
Piazza's parents Jim and Evelyn they
knew that our son was in bad shape and
he could likely die they let him die
they killed our son the Piazza family
attorney said in a statement the parents
of Tim Piazza are pleased to see the
first beta brother accept responsibility
for his actions and encourage others who
also contributed to Tim's death to
follow in his footsteps
Burke decided to submit an open plea
meaning he pleaded guilty without
knowing his possible sentence and for
the first time we could hear from Burke
during his sentencing hearing on July
31st Burke faces fines of up to a year
in jail for each of the four counts of
hazing Norah tarika thank you you know
we've talked to the Piazza before and I
met with them and when I heard this news
last night I thought finally someone is
beginning to accept responsibility for
what happened and every time we hear
this story I think about the parents
because as you know they were here at
the table the fact that they are
speaking up about something so painful
well ultimately I think lead to change
because they want people to know they
don't want this to happen to anybody
else as painful as this is for them you
look at their pictures of their son it's
heartbreaking to see and the way it
leads to change is somebody about to do
something stupid stops and yes this is
where this can lead after seeing exactly
how awful this is